hagard et au quatrième et dernière vidéo
cette fois c'est vraiment la dernière au
micro a buggé donc laquelle était pas
top
je ne sens pas les steaks hockey
aujourd'hui mon fils est revenu hier sur
un gardien pour finir premier c'est la
dernière vidéo sur ce jeu wii play c'est
parti on va péter les qu ils sont
immenses on n'a pas peur d'eux ils nous
font pas peur
on est au dessus ça à mon grand
aujourd'hui on adopte la stratégie du ne
pas se diviser en deux
za correctement ou pas moi je suis
d'accord avec moi même donc déjà c'est
l'important dans un premier temps voilà
il n'y a pas de conflit inter
corporelles à tripoli mon nom est
toujours allé parler
j'adore la politesse est le polystyrène
jugeait pas l'avantagé du je mange des
points je ne suis pas de romans je suis
tranquille voilà si l'occasion se
présente
on mange quelqu'un tu occasions se
présentent pas celle attendue jeudi les
échéances auxquelles on se prétend
pardon ce speed pas de regret des vastes
que je viens de faire
german bailleur vient d'en haut les
ahlaouis pas aux gets à moi
gervais et j'aurais mouillé mon cas sans
que j'aie envie de baiser lui voilà
tiens tu les pistons beeston mois elle
se plaît plus tôt il a bien voulu biz
stone est assurée il faut être patient
mon païs beaufort du faux pas je me
laisse aller
moi j'adore je te plaît te plaire je
suis allé au russe pour moi ça c'est toi
il se fit les gros connard vous avez de
la manger comme ça ils se mettent la
nourriture dans la bouche mais on a fait
un vrai bon mais arrivé ique il anus
voilà voilà la maturité partant de
reclassement le deuxième s'appelle tokyo
je crois qu'au respect voire mature que
nous encore elle pour cor faith elle te
plait pas un coup de poker
tu viens vers moi avec tout mais je te
mange vient le beau gosse mais par
contre on avait dit il ne faut pas ce
split et les enfants dora guerriau pour
gagner il ne faut pas rater lâché
gaubert je me bats l'année sur mon
tricycle à trois roues et d'un coup je
voyais un rouge je lui parlais je lui ai
demandé si elle est bien je veux manger
comme ça pendant que papa je tue votre
anus vous voyez ce que merde j'ai fait
fondre plus celui-là nues sort tu ne
sais plus quoi faire steam tu paniques
steam tu allais échange tu pourras
jamais faire ça tu pourras jamais faire
ça 2 mois de ça non
jeu fédérer premier l'arrivée salle à
manger la banane tum tristement tue près
ça va mais non mais pourquoi ça me fait
ça donc toutes les vidéos c'est pour moi
ces moments je sais ma nourriture et un
mickael la vole comme ça maintenant
c'est plutôt une triste et tim triste
au casone séparons pas de panique pas on
panique pas on va aller destroy you and
us voilà et baala ça fait quoi comment
se fait larguer comme ça on se sent mal
ah c'est toi qui me les mariages en deux
secondes ou pas ah ouais c'est toi bats
fait de mal à ma mère je la connais elle
travaille à la comptable de l'accueil
allez tiens on va les laisser la revue
ta mère c'est pour ça qu'ils aient à
monsieur adore rigoler vient bien je
suis en va être bien au deal il impose
le respect 10la instant elle reste pour
elle dans le sud je connais bien c'est
un ami oh non je suis bon petit bébé
dort jean haja ils purent écouter on
l'entend crier allons nous bientôt faire
notre entrée dans le top 10 je pense
qu'au final je vais pleurer c'est pas
bien non pas toi patois bas noirs je
taisais cet univers je fais un
référendum
j'ai interdit désormais la présence de
ces connards de riber dans agathe wario
larroy stationnement pouvait venir voir
voilà c'est vous les montrer voyez givet
jean baptiste
eh bien regardez le bien viens là jean
baptiste jean baptiste du moins bien
bien réagi mais mais un gamin gamme
était tellement une sous merde je ne
range pas sur un gars yacht est enfermé
bien là rien non je regrette
immédiatement cette décision en facebook
fait sont pas bonnes le pam est le bouc
jeux qui t'apprennent pour toi team s'il
te plaît j'achète des jeux
tous les jours sur toi j'adore son
interface j'adore ta manière de mettre
les jeux plus cher qu'il ne vend rien à
lever un bout de postes et une boutade
bobo la peau lainée sur moi mais je
pense qu'il a un bon polaroïd mais
j'suis pas sûr que cette blague était
bonne et je m'assure que cette blague
était une blague
d'ailleurs je suis le dixième à lui si
je mens je devais terriblement bien
contente non non non non non la tension
est énorme
arrêté le brusquer pas aux ondes de choc
passé 10e mon coeur va s'y forme je peux
pas le manger mais si je me suis teint
ans je jouais pas non non non non non
non clairement pas vois pas faire que de
regarder les coincer
[Musique]
je m'arrache me marc bellemare bellemare
c'est faux nom surtout surtout ne pas
céder au péché de gourmandise
voilà merci tu m'appelles ces panneaux
mais là ont duré cinq heures faut pas
déconner faut pas déconner faut pas
faire n'importe quoi au monde à lui
comment ça va je te pose quand je
pouvais pas le manger non regardez vous
ce but il n'a peur oui regardez il avait
eu la même jauge annabis qu ils allaient
le bouffer on va manger team williams tu
n'auras jamais noah reton jouets
mécaniques
elles n'étaient pas de très haut enfin
quand on est 3e
we have j'avais la pression foetale dans
le caniveau
à
l'agencé d'avancé sur la guerre ayant
cette fois c'était la dernière on a vu
les premières attend d'être objectif
merci à tous j'ai sa septième vous en
rappeler c'est le cas n'hésitez pas aimé
la vidéo comme d'habitude c'est en fait
j'aime parce qu'on a fini premier
bordels ont atteint cet unique but qu'on
avait dans la vie et en maintenant que
qu'est ce qu'on va devenir
mais j'adore regarder c'était super on
s'en sort très bientôt ne s'était pas de
vidéos tudou pis
[Musique]